PROFESSOR: Hi.
In this clip, we're going to go
through problem two of the
transcription and translation
unit.
We're also going to review all
of the information you would
need to fill out problem
one, the table.
If you haven't tried these
problems yet on your own,
please pause the video now and
try them, and then come back
and watch this explanation.
OK.
So here we have, as in problem
two, the double stranded DNA.
Now, this is a piece of the
eukaryotic genome, and so this
DNA is in the nucleus
of the cell.
Now what we're going to do is
we're going to go through
transcription and translation
with this gene.
So the first thing we need to
do is we need to figure out
where we want to start
transcription and in what
direction we want to go and what
strand we want to use as
our template.
So in the problem, we're given
our promoter region and we're
given that our transcription
starts right here at this
arrow and moves in
this direction.
So we know where we're starting
and what direction
we're moving in.
All transcription will proceed
reading a template in the
three prime to five prime
direction and will polymerize
the RNA made in the five prime
to three prime direction.
So what we need to do now is
figure out what strand is
going in the three prime to five
prime direction and the
direction that we're going
to be transcribed.
So that means that this strand,
which is going from
three prime over here down to
five prime at the end, this is
going to be our template
strand.
So our template strand is going
to be at the bottom.
OK.
So when our RNA polymerase
starts, it's going to be
reading this template strand
and adding nucleic acid,
adding nucleotide triphosphates,
or NTPs, one by
one together to make the RNA.
Now it's going to add these
together by adding a
phosphodiester bond in between
all of the monomers.
So we're going to start
our transcription.
And basically, what I need
to do is just use the
complimentary base pair
to my template strand.
So I'm going to write
it out here.
So I've done a lot of
transcription here.
Now where am I going to
stop my transcription?
I'm not going to stop
just randomly in
the middle of nowhere.
What my RNA polymerase is going
to do is it's going to
stop when it gets to the end of
this terminator sequence.
So I'm going to keep
transcribing until I get to
the end of my terminator here.
OK.
So this is my RNA strand.
And as I said before, we're
going to polymerize this mRNA
in the five prime to three
prime direction.
OK, we've got our mRNA.
Since this is a eukaryotic cell
and the mRNA right now is
in the nucleus, what we need to
do is transport it out of
the nucleus and into the
cytoplasm where it will be
translated by a ribosome.
Now what the ribosome is going
to do is it's going to take
this mRNA, which is a message
that encodes the sequence of
amino acids that we need to
put together to make the
protein, and we're going to take
this message and we're
going to find a place to
start translation.
So what the ribosome is going
to do is it's going to start
at the five prime end of the
template and read towards the
three prime end of
the template.
It's going to read until it
gets to a start codon.
The start codon is AUG.
So this is where we're going
to start, and AUG encodes
methionine.
We're then going to read in
three base pair codons down
from the five prime end of our
template to the three prime
end of our template.
And so we're going to keep
going in this translation
until we reach what's
called a stop codon.
Now there are three
stop codons.
Stop codons are UAA,
UGA, and UAG.
So if when my ribosome finds any
of these three codons in
frame, it's going to stop.
So I get all the way down here
before I hit a stop codon on
this transcript.
So what my ribosome is going
to be doing as it's reading
these codons is it's going to
insert amino acid by amino
acid, pairing them together
with a peptide bond.
So we've got methionine bonded
to histidine, tyrosine,
leucine, and so on
and so forth.
OK, so this is the protein chain
that's encoded by this
gene in the DNA.
And in proteins, we always
synthesize from the N terminus
to the C terminus.
OK, so we've gone through both
transcription and translation.
Now what we want to do is we
want to take into account what
would happen if we had a
mutation in our sequence.
So in this case, in this
problem, we're going to insert
a base pair right here.
So we're going to insert
an extra T here
and an extra A here.
Now, if this is happening in
the DNA, when our DNA is
transcribed to make our
RNA, what's going to
happen to the RNA?
Well, we're going to also add
the corresponding base into
our RNA, so we're going to
have an extra U here.
So in addition to only adding
one nucleotide in our RNA,
this is also going to throw
off our frame that we're
reading when our ribosome
is reading our RNA.
So instead of the frame that we
had previously, we're now
going to have a new frame.
So it's going to start at the
same start codon and then read
this codon just as normal, but
then this U will make UUA and
then will read in codons
of three from there.
So again, I need to translate
until I hit a stop codon.
And so the stop codon is going
to be different in this case,
because this stop codon
is no longer in frame.
I need to find an in
frame stop codon.
And the first stop codon that I
hit is going to be this you
UAG right here.
And so our new protein sequence
is now going to be N
terminus, and then the beginning
is going to be very
similar, and then our amino
acids are going to be
completely different because
we're reading this in a
different frame.
OK, so we can see how this one
mutation, addition of one base
pair into our DNA, has caused
us to create a completely
different peptide.
It's probably not going to
perform the same function.
OK.
So we've gone over transcription
and translation.
You should be able at this
point to answer all of
question two and you should
also be able to fill in
all of table one.
Thank you for watching.